وقبل ان نكمل ملفات هذه النشره نتوقف مع
التطورات في شبه جزيره القرم حيث اعلن
الحاكم الروسي لمدينه
تعرضت لهجوم الصاروخي جديد وانه تم تفعيل
اجهزه الانذار الجوي واضاف ان الدفاعات
الجويه تصدت لصاروخ معاد في سيفاستوبل
وقال ان حطاما الصاروخ سقط بالقرب من مرسى
صخر نايا بالكا قرب المدينه كما اعلنت
سلطاته عن ايقاف قوارب وسفن نقل الركاب في
خليج سيفا ستوبل مؤقتا
لمتابعه هذه التطورات معنا من موسكو
مراسله يوسف وايضا بروجيا مراسل الجزيره
لاسكرام ارحب بكم ابداء معك سامي يوسف بعد
تطورات الامس في شبه جزيره القرم تعود الى
الواجهه اليوم من جديد ماذا في التفاصيل
التفاصيل حتى الان ما ذكرته ازدهار لم
تصدر عن السلطات الروسيه ان كان في موسكو
او حتى في شبه الجزيره جزيره القرم
تحديثات اخرى وما هو مهم بالنسبه للسلطات
هناك بان لا ضحايا بهذا بهذه الشظايا التي
سقطت فوق تلك المنطقه هذا يعني بان
الهجمات الاوكرانيه
مستمره على شبه الجزيره هناك وتستهدف
تحاول ان تستهدف بطبيعه الحال البناء
التحتيه العسكريه للقوات الروسيه يوم امس
اسطول البحر الاسود
واليوم محاوله جديده من محاولات سلاح الجو
الاوكراني لاستهداف تلك الاجزاء بعيدا عن
خط المواجهه في اوكرانيا الذي يشهد بحسب
السلطات الروسيه تقدما في بعض المناطق ان
كان على محور
محاور مختلفه في دونيتس وحتى صدها جماد في
خرسون وقتل المئات من الجنود الاوكرانيين
يقرا من هذا بان القوات الاوكرانيه قد
تكون تريد فتح جبهات اخرى
لتشتيت الانتباه بالنسبه للقوات الروسيه
ولكن بالتالي دائما ما تتحدث القوات
الروسيه باستثناء يوم امس عندما استهدف
اسطول البحر الاسود كانت دائما ما تتحدث
عن صد هجمات بمسيارات وصواريخ تستهدف شبه
جزيره القرن
سامر في ذات الوقت او بالتزامن بالاحرى
هناك تطورات ميدانيه ايضا في الداخل
الاوكراني نرفدها معك اليسكا
نعم بالفعل ازدهار حتى هذه الساعه لم
يتبنى الجيش الاوكراني المسؤوليه عن هذا
الهجوم الجديد في شبه جزيره القرم لكن لم
يعد سرا وخافيا على ان القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه ربما تكون معنيه في الاعلاني
عن مثل هذه الهجمات التي تستهدف المواقع
العسكريه الروسيه في القرن وثمه اهداف
استراتيجيه كما يبدو من وراء تلك الهجمات
التي تستهدف هذه القواعد العسكريه الروسيه
الاول ربما يتركز في مساله تجريد او توجيه
ضربات عسكريه لهذه المواقع والامر
الاستراتيجي الثاني هو محاوله القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه اعاقه الامدادات
الروسيه التي تاتي من القرب الى الجبهه
الجنوبيه ومن الواضح بان القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه نجحت في تسديد عده ضربات نوعيه
في الايام والاسابيع الماضيه للوجود
العسكري الروسي في شبه جزيره القرن ليس
واضحا الى اي مدى نجحت هذه الهجمات لكن
القوات الاوكرانيه تقول بانها ضربات
استراتيجيه منسقه بدات باستيلاء الاستيلاء
على منصات الغاز في البحر الاسود التي كان
الجيش الروسي قد سيطر عليها في بدايه
الحرب توجيه الضربات العسكريه ايضا لمطار
ساكي الذي يستخدم من قبل القوات الروسيه
لضرب العمق الاوكراني استهداف الغواصه
والبارجه الحربيه الروسيه في القرن وايضا
هذه الهجمات كانت ممكنه ومتاحه بالنسبه
للقوات الاوكرانيه بعد توجيه عده ضربات
لمنظومه الرادارات الروسيه في القرن
والتوجيهي ايضا ضربات عسكريه
لمنظومات دفاعيه من نوع اس
400 في القرن شكرا جزيلا لك ميزابولوجيا
مراسله الجزيره ليس كرام ومن موسكو مراسل
الجزيره سامر يوسف